الواضح
مرحله وبدايه اخرى مرحله يامر المشاركون
في مؤتمر العمليات السياسيه في السودان ان
تؤسس لتحول ديمقراطيه بعد حسم اهم القضايا
تفكيك النظام السابق على راس اجنده
المؤتمر في العمليه السياسيه التي تواجه
تحديات عده وصلت الى مرحله التقييم من قبل
الموقعي ده على الاتفاق الايطالي
للوصول الى نهايات هذه العمليه الان
الدوله بالاداب بتاعها ما قادره توفيق
المطالبه النقابيه مطالب مشروعه هنا داخل
مؤتمر المرحله النهائيه للعمليه السياسيه
تجد قضايا تفكيك النظام السابق والعداله
الانتقاليه وهيكله القوات النظاميه حفظها
من النقاش والتداول اما خارج هذه القاعه
فيتصدر الوضع الاقتصادي والمعيشي هموم
الناس
هنا ترتفعوا اصوات احتجاجات نقابين مئات
الموظفين بديوان الضرائب يطالبون بتحسين
الظروف عملهم ووضعهم الميشيه فلجوء امل
وزملائها للاحتجاج ياتي بعد استنفاده كافه
الطرق القانونيه للمطالبه بحقوقهم كما
يقولون
[موسيقى]
في المشهد ايضا الاف من الطلاب الرافدين
زياده الرسوم الدراسيه الجامعيه لطلاب
القبول العام رسوم وصلت نسبتها الى 900 في
المئه مقارنه بالعام الماضي
الطلاب ليسوا وحدهم في رجب الاحتجاجات
نواب الاختصاصيين من الاطباء ينفذون وقفه
احتجاجيه رفضا لمضاعفه رسوم الامتحانات
والتدريب واقعون اقتصادي يرى مختصون ان
تداعياته ستنعكس على مجمل العمليه
السياسيه الحاليه هذه المطالبات تؤثر يعني
على العمليه السياسيه وان كان احد مطلوبات
نجاح العمليه السياسيه التقديم بعض
التنازلات من كل فئه المجتمع يعني يتوافق
مع كل ذلك انه مستوى هذا التاثير ربما
يعني يطيح بالعمليه السياسيه
والى حين الوصول الى استقرار سياسي يفضي
الى حكومه مدنيه تستمر الاحتجاجات في ظل
تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي ووقف الدعم الدولي
عن السودان نزار البغداوي الجزيره الخرطوم